hey what's up guys remember the m50 s
that i've raved about in previous videos
there beastly studio monitors that i've
used to edit my past hundred or so
videos and one of the favorites of
fellow youtuber Austin from Duncan 3
through 303 well it's time to do
something a little special with these
this time duncan 3 through 303 and i are
teaming up to give away a pair of the
limited edition em 50's which are
basically identical to the standard pair
that we've used but with a slightly
sexier outer shell so yeah pretty much
boss status here and leaving a comment
on this video is all you have to do to
enter to win a pair so you're in boom
golden thumbs up on this video would
also really help a lot I'd appreciate it
the ratings do help and being a
subscriber of course also makes you
golden because I have a pretty fun video
coming up next so look forward to that
but yeah between the videos that we have
gone up here on the same day one of your
comments will be selected to win so you
might want to leave a comment entry on
both of our videos so there you go guys
the rules for entering are really simple
you can get your entries right there in
the comment section below and you can
enter for one week so one week from
today on April 15 the comments section
will close and I will pick one winner
and message them from my personal
account so if you get someone messaging
you from someone who's pretending to be
me on maybe my second account I don't
have a second account you will have to
get a message from me on the day that
the winner is picked in order to win so
I'll let you guys know who won on
Twitter that day too either way thanks
for watching enjoy your holiday weekend
good luck and I'll talk to you guys in
the next video thanks
[Music]